hi i'm matt from codetech tutorials
today i want to talk about
something that a lot of coders should
really
think about or keep in mind or anyone
even preparing to be a coder
for some of us that comes naturally for
the rest well we have to
push ourselves we have to study extra
hard we have to
think about things from angles we're not
used to thinking about
i'm going to talk about four tips to
avoid burnout
or tips to keep going these are tips i
use
this list is subjective incredibly
subjective
what works for me might not work for you
but i can say for sure that these four
things have definitely
helped me keeping my mindset straight
keeping me
learning code studying the code because
that's pretty much
what i do every day and it is true that
there are some days i don't particularly
feel like it at first but we'll address
that
so one of the main things one of the
very very main things is you need to set
small goals for yourself sure you want
larger overarching goals and we'll get
to that
but what small goals do is they leave
you something attainable
you can sit down start working on your
project and think i just want this
little tiny thing to be better or look
better
if i can just obtain that then i'll be
set you know
you'll feel good about it so what these
small goals do
is they allow you to feel good and
actually get some code done
because it's actually pretty important
to code
frequently even if you don't feel like
it
you have to code every day even if it's
something small
and this isn't like 100 set in stone
maybe you have a holiday
and you just physically can't actually
sit down to code because
maybe you're with family the whole time
and distracted or who knows
if you just have free time and you're
just sitting around
not doing a whole lot yeah you should
absolutely be coding and if you can't
bring yourself to maybe these tips will
help
all right one of the things i do when
i'm really stuck i don't feel like doing
anything
and i don't even feel like working on
maybe one big project or something
is i go look at job listings now the
reason i do this
is mainly for the list of technologies
that are actually
in use these days you hear the same
things over and over on most forums
react view js python
is there even anything else in the world
if you look at like youtube coding
videos they're probably you wouldn't
know that there are any
is anything else in the world other than
those like four things
but if you look at job listings they've
got 20 to 30 technologies listed
sometime
of things that they actually use in
production so
what i like to do is just go through
those one by one
and see which ones i don't know and i
take a note of the ones i have
no idea what they are and i go look it
up and study it for a little bit
and sometimes inspiration will strike
i'll see something
like oh i can do something cool with
this and i'll
have that in the back of my mind and
maybe i might try to implement it later
but it kind of gets you out of the
pattern of not looking at anything
because you're kind of broadening your
your scope a little bit one of the
things that tends to happen
after a while when you're programming
for a long time is you get stuck in this
rut of like doing the same thing
so looking at this big list of
technologies and research and all the
ones you're not
real keen on will kind of broaden your
knowledge for a bit and
help you get creative in other areas
that way when you do come back to the
main thing you focus on
all the time at least you have a little
bit more perspective and that can make a
big difference and keep it
more exciting at least it does for me
and another thing that's really big is
is to have a personal passion project
and if you don't have one make one and
let it change
as frequently as it feels like and
that's totally up to you as soon as your
first one
falls out of your favor and you don't
feel like working on it anymore
make a new one fix something find
something in the world that could be
better
find it find a tool that you need that
you would love but just can't find and
start building it
it doesn't have to be good you don't
even have to finish it you just need to
have something to work on and you need
to explore
maybe you'll finish it maybe it will get
good but in any case
most learning comes from failure so even
if you try to do something and you find
out oh this is too big
i can't do all this this is too much
work you'll learn a lot
and then when you go look at other
technologies and see how they work
things will start tying together you
just got to keep doing this over and
over
it's a lot of repetition it takes a
really long time to become a good
programmer
programming it needs a lot of discreet
math
and well not all you know not all
programming if you're just like making
web pages you don't really need a whole
lot of
discrete math but if you're doing games
in 3d
and trying to make things as efficient
as possible without the memories moving
around
it does take a lot of discreet math
so that's the big four things i'm going
to end it here so number one
small goals for you do not compare
yourself to other
people's small goals set your own
personal small goals something you can
obtain so only compare yourself and set
those small goals
and program every day pretty much no
matter what just work on one of these
little small goals
and look at job listings when you're
stuck and just look at technologies
get ideas just start broadening things
if you're feeling too pigeonholed and
can't take it anymore fourth last but
not least have your own personal passion
project and let it change as often as it
needs to
just to keep you going this you you
probably know as well as i do that
if you're into technology and
programming things
you know you kind of if you're working
on a big project you kind of get
stuck after a while so i think this
personal
passion project is the biggest one or at
least it has been for me
and the other things just kind of fold
into that hope you enjoyed this video
hope it helps you in some way hope it
maybe helps you get out of a rut if
you're in a rut or it just helps you
keep going or use it as motivation
to keep programming the world does need
good programmers
as you can tell by the large amount of
crashing software
and bugs in production you are needed if
you can
keep getting better every day you can
make a difference trying to just be
motivational here all right
matt from code second tutorials over and
out appreciate
all you guys that do watch my channel it
does mean a lot
i'm i'm still a little uh struck with
how fast it's
growing and it's uh i just get a little
flustered when i even talk about it so
it just means so much to me i don't even
know how to express it so thank you guys
please let me know down below what you
think my patreon does have some voting
open for what i will
definitely work on just need some people
over there to actually vote and you can
say
hey work on this video do it but
otherwise
you know the comments are always with a
bit of grain of salt because the public
youtube comments uh
so i don't really go off of any final
thing there but on patreon i will
because that's like you know actually
paid supporters so
appreciate you guys peace out
you